hi welcome to hannity we have a busy
news friday night for you our
expectations for joe biden they're
already extremely low
but through 14 months in office he has
somehow he managed to even do worse than
we predicted everything now is in crisis
it was all preventable everything our
schools our cities our borders our
safety our security our economy war in
europe america is abandoned in
afghanistan by the way we're keeping
track at state 237
and 250 days since joe biden said he
would not abandon them here at home
millions are struggling to fill their
gas tanks heat their homes and put food
on the table but tonight it's joe biden
who's full of complaints today whining
that republicans weren't nicer to his
supreme court nominee and he even
accused them of verbal abuse take a look
at this
i knew it wouldn't be easy
but i knew the person i nominated will
be put through a painful and difficult
confirmation process
but i have to tell you
what judge jackson was put through
was well beyond that
there was verbal abuse the anger
the constant interruptions
the most vile baseless assertions and
accusations
they pointed out a simple fact that she
went easy in these child porn cases in
terms of sentencing that's all they did
did they filibuster
her nomination like biden did to judge
janice rogers brown because he didn't
want republicans to ultimately nominate
an african-american woman to the u.s
supreme court did they assassinate her
character like then senator biden did to
clarence thomas in 1991 justice thomas
referred to joe biden's smear campaign
as a high-tech lynching and did
republicans accused judge jackson of
gang rape without a single shred of
evidence to support those claims you
might remember this joe
did you consume alcohol during your high
school years so you're saying there's
never been a case where you drank so
much that you didn't remember what
happened the night before or part of
what happened uh
in your yearbook
you talked about
drinking
and sexual exploits did you not
so you were not as a
sloppy drunk and so your roommate was
lying from my standpoint
as a black american as far as i'm
concerned it is a high-tech lynching for
uppity blacks
who in any way deign to think for
themselves
to do for themselves
to have different ideas
and it is a message
that unless you cow town to an old order
this is what will happen to you
you will be lynched
destroyed
caricatured
by a committee of the u.s u.s senate
rather than hung from a tree
and joe biden you led that smear against
justice thomas and as far as i'm
concerned after trying to ruin the lives
of brett kavanaugh and justice thomas
democrats have no right to complain
about the treatment of any nominee for
any reason especially joe biden kamala
harris who waged a full-blown witch-hunt
against two
reputable justices but tonight it's not
totally clear that biden even remembers
what happened to either clarence thomas
or justice cavanaugh because we all know
that joe biden is in a very steep
cognitive decline it is becoming more
and more evident more obvious more
transparent every single day here's
today's joe video of the day take a look
my name is joe biden please sit down i'm
jill's husband
and naomi biden's grandfather
uh folks uh
now yesterday uh this is not only a
sunny day i mean it's from the bottom of
my heart
this is gonna let so much shine sun
shine on so many
young women
we're meeting with judge jackson senator
duckworth introduced her to 11 year old
is it vivian
vivine
vivian i'm sorry vivian
america is a nation that can be defined
in a single word
i was going to put him a foot
excuse me in the foothills of the
himalayas with xi jinping
traveling with him unless we traveled 17
000 miles when i was vice president i
don't know that for a fact
not only are the american people
watching this
president xi is watching this putin's
watching this the mueller's in iran i'm
watching this kim jong-un are watching
this
the taliban's watching this world's
enemies are watching this this
administration is nothing but a dumpster
fire you have a president struggling
with even speaking basic simple tasks
putting sentences together the biden
syndicate by the way also facing a
possible indictment the vice president
well she's got her own embarrassing
moments and of course the never ending
giggling at inappropriate times our
economy is imploding food prices are
soaring gas prices at record levels
interest rates are now beginning to
surge a 40-year high in inflation the
bank of america now warning of an
imminent recession things frankly
couldn't get any worse but white house
staffers they're now openly complaining
the media is not sufficiently touting
their historic success
what success
exactly what are you talking about they
take responsibility for nothing 40-year
high of inflation record high gas prices
a disaster leaving the islamic emirates
of afghanistan not being ready for war
in europe with vladimir putin
oh energy prices that he caused because
he artificially reduced the world supply
remember the white house blames vladimir
putin for everything because of the war
in europe that happened under their
watch yeah putin's a thug he's a
criminal the axis committee and his
troops are committing a pure evil he
only responds to strength but sadly joe
biden is the weakest leader that i have
seen in my lifetime so now here we are
months into vladimir putin's hostile
invasion of a sovereign country and this
week the devastating scenes on the
ground in ukraine are really hard to
watch if you have a conscience and you
have a soul putin's brutality evil knows
no bounds and earlier today russian
forces they shelled a train station in
eastern europe filled with innocent
citizens innocent civilians they were
just attempting to flee the war zone and
you got dozens and dozens that are now
dead or seriously injured including an
untold number of dead kids but biden is
still blocking poland from what
delivering fighter jets to ukraine why
in fact most of the lethal aid the u.s
is sending to ukraine is happening in
spite of joe biden not because of joe
biden he doesn't even seem to care about
what is exactly going on in ukraine and
he doesn't really seem to care about
anything that doesn't directly impact
him or a member of his immediate family
because according to a new poll
americans no longer think biden is
likable or and by the way for good
reason joe biden is a low-functioning
self-centered corrupt career politician
who frankly needed to retire 20 years
ago hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else